we're asked to factor this expression
and there is going to be simpler ways to
factor it but in this video I'm going to
factor it by grouping and when you
factor by grouping what you need to do
is think about two numbers whose
products are going to be equal to yeah
but actually a 1 coefficient right here
right T squared is the same thing as 1 T
squared so we're looking for two numbers
let's call them a and B a times B the
product of these two numbers need to be
the product of the coefficient on the T
squared which is 1 and the negative 15
right here so a times B has to be equal
to 1 times negative 15 or just negative
15 and the sum of a and B and a plus B
needs to be equal to negative 2
a plus B needs to be equal to negative 2
and once we have these two numbers I can
show you how we can use those to factor
by grouping and in other videos I've
actually broken down to why this
technique works now let's think of the
different factors of 15 when we take
their products and if we take the sum if
we can somehow get to negative 2 so
let's look at the different factors of
negative of negative 15 so we could do
let me do it in this other limited in
pink see if 1 and negative 15 these are
so everything I list here is going to
their product is going to be negative 15
but let's think about what happens when
you take their sum so 1 and negative 15
the sum is negative 14 and if you did
negative 1 and + 15 you're just going to
get the negative of that you're gonna
get 14 it does not equal negative 2 so
what happens if you take what happens if
you take 3 and negative 5 so their
product is definitely negative 15 3 plus
negative 5 is negative 2 so that works
and if we saw negative we try negative 3
& 5
first we got that be positive just like
oh we just have to swap the signs and
we've gotten a negative 2 so these work
3 and negative 5 work 3 times negative 5
is negative 15 3 plus negative 5 is
negative 2 so what we want to do here is
break this middle term up here we know
that 3 plus negative 5 is equal to
negative 2 so we can break up this
middle term here as
some of and well I'll do it right you're
actually doing the same color so this
thing here we can rewrite as T squared
I'll put the minus 15 out here but the
negative 2t we can rewrite as the sum of
3t we could write it here as plus 3t
plus 3t minus 5t minus 5t and when
you're trying to figure out which one to
put first or second you just have you
should look at these these other terms
and say which ones have common factors
the 3 and 5 both have a common factor
with 15 so it would have you it it's not
as obvious which one to put first so
we're just going to go with this 3t
minus 5t I got that from 3t minus 5t is
equal to negative 2t positive 3 times
negative 5 is equal to negative 15
that's where it came from
now we're ready to factor by grouping so
let's take the first group let's take
these first two terms right there and
what's the common factor there well a
common factor there is T so if i factor
T out that becomes T times T squared
divided by T is T 3 T divided by T is 3
so this these first two terms are the
same thing as T times T plus 3 now let's
look at these second two terms let's
look at these second two terms right
here what's a common factor well they're
both divisible by negative 5 so let's
factor out a negative 5 let's factor out
a negative 5 and negative 5t ty divided
by negative 5 or if you factor out the
negative 5 you're just gonna have a T
there and then negative 15 if you factor
out a negative 5 you divide negative 15
by negative 5 I'm going to have a
positive 3 it's gonna have a positive 3
and then notice boat you now have two
terms here are two products and they
both have the common factor they both
have the common factor of T plus 3 so we
can rewrite this right here as a product
of T plus 3
we run distributing the T plus 3 we're
factoring out the T plus 3 T plus 3
times T right because times t minus 5
minus 5 and i want you to really make
sure you feel good that these are real
the same thing if you take T times T
plus three and factor out the T plus
three you're just left with that T if
you take negative five times T plus
three and you factor out the T plus
three you're just left with that
negative five but once you factor out
the T plus three nor just left with a t
minus five you have fully factored this
expression here and a future we're going
to see easier ways of doing this but
factoring by grouping is actually the
the easiest way to do it if you have a
non coefficient higher than one or
non-one coefficient could also be a
negative coefficient out front here when
you have one as your coefficient here
there's actually much easier ways to
factor something like this but it's
really the same thought process